we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p people call
in sometimes people ask david I've been
leaving voicemails but you never play my
voicemails why aren't you playing my
voicemail so before we play today since
it's short let me just give a couple
tips if I may number one you'll notice
that we rarely play a voicemail that's
two or three minutes long it's a Google
Voice number which maxes out at three
minutes so if you want to increase the
odds that your voicemail is played
don't leave a two to three-minute
voicemail right leave a forty to fifty
second maybe if it's really good a 60
second voicemail because that tends to
be what gets selected you don't need a
rambling Prelude before you get to your
question so you get right into it out of
the chase that's exactly right
number two full disclosure we do receive
fifty to sixty voicemails a day and we
play for a week yeah okay
so I mean that it's just it's important
to understand the math and I know that
by saying that I risk that some people
will just get tired of calling but that
that's the the truth of it so I don't be
offended if we're not playing your voice
we almost need another full-time
employee yeah just to go through all
those voicemail that's exactly right
well we're gonna have to hire someone
else just to manage the voicemails okay
anyway two one nine to david p here is
today's voicemail hey david this is
Marcus Moreno calling from Laredo Texas
and I was wondering one dollar from gets
in peach how are you celibate or what
you're gonna do how you make the
ceremony or what yeah no ceremony
listen I've said before I don't think
it's particularly likely that Trump gets
impeached I think if it gets to that he
will resign and number two I that
there's wide disagreement about this in
our audience I don't know that the best
thing is for Trump to go I think the
best thing for the left might be a
scandal ridden and basically a
politically impotent Trump to stay
through 2018 where Democrats make major
gains in the House and Senate and
eventually to 2020 where Trump gets
defeated I am increasingly convinced
that that's actually the best scenario
it's a very presumptuous voice panel
isn't it because it assumes that one
Donald Trump will be impeached and that
I'll tell you they were gonna celebrate
and neither one of those things would
probably happen I think neither is
likely I think that's true great bonus
show today Steve ban and a stepping down
from his post at Breitbart H&M is
apologizing again for a dense ibly very
very racist ad we will also talk about
how likely it is that if you have one
cigarette you become a daily cigarette
smoker get access to the bonus show by
signing up at david pakman.com slash
membership and or by becoming a $5 a
month patron at patreon.com slash david
pakman show speak to you on the bonus
show